the government will launch an ambitious
experiment this Sunday to improve the
health of all Americans the National
Institutes of Health wants 1 million
Americans to donate DNA and share their
health habits in the name of science
participants in the all of us study will
give blood and urine samples and
describe lifestyle habits the database
will be part of a 1.4 billion dollar
precision medicine initiative its goal
is to discover new ways to prevent and
treat several diseases but the efforts
raising concerns about patient privacy
and the risk hackers could reach such a
large database NIH director dr. Francis
Collins joins us from its headquarters
in Bethesda Maryland dr. Collins good
morning good morning Gail Anthony bianna
it's nice to be with you this morning to
talk about this exciting project it's
it's great to have you call this study a
national adventure that's going to
transform medical care what exactly do
you hope to accomplish well do you ever
feel when somebody's making
recommendations to you about how to stay
healthy or when you need a prescription
and you're wondering is this the right
drug for me at the right dose a lot of
what we do in medicine is
one-size-fits-all precision medicine is
this opportunity to make things much
more individualized and therefore more
precise and more likely to result in a
good outcome but to get to that point we
need to collect a lot of data on a lot
of people who are willing to partner
with us in this remarkable adventure I
called all of us we named it that for
good reason it is about all of us and
it's going to give us the information we
currently lack how do people sign up for
this program so it the big launch is
this coming Sunday May the 6th and at
that point if you go to the internet
site join all of us dot org join all of
us just one word no spaces you can find
out what it takes to sign up there'll be
a number of educational steps there
you'll need to go through then you'll
have to decide whether you want to
consent to take part in this people who
sign up will then be given a chance to
give blood samples and urine samples and
answer other question there's and make
their electronic health records
available in a very secure database
that will allow researchers to begin to
understand all of those things we don't
know that will lead to better healthcare
dr. Francis Collins I love your
enthusiasm about the project I am
curious though about the privacy
concerns that people have you know we
have a story in the news where a serial
killer was just caught recently with the
DNA from a relative so how do you assure
people that the information they're
giving will be kept private so all of
their information will be stripped of
personal identifiers there'll be no
names or social security numbers or
addresses or dates of birth the
information that researchers will want
to look at will be anonymized and
researchers will be required to pledge
that they will not seek to identify who
these individuals are and furthermore
based on some new legislation passed a
little more than a year ago this
database will be protected from any kind
of use by law enforcement who are
browsing around trying to find potential
criminals as was the case with the
Golden State killer so this is very well
protected the database is encrypted of
course we all worry about hackers and
ways in which these kinds of databases
may be attractive targets and we've gone
through hackathons by the way we've
already enrolled as a beta test sort of
a trial of this more than 26,000 people
they've gone through this process
they've agreed that it's worth it to
sign up because they're gonna find out a
lot about themselves and so far the
security of the system seems to be
absolutely the best that can be obtained
at the present time ultimately what
health problems is is going to is this
information going to target pretty much
anything that is common enough to have a
bunch of individuals affected by that
condition when you have a million people
that's gonna mean a lot of things so let
me just give you an example diabetes
probably with a million people signing
up there will be 80 or 90 thousand of
those folks who have diabetes we'll be
able to figure out what's the right
intervention for each of those as
opposed to the way we currently manage
the disease which is one size fits all
and certainly this idea of being able to
get all right doctor I'm so we love your
enthusiasm I'm so sorry but we have to
move on in the show but thank you and
thank you so much for telling us about
this program we appreciate you joining
us sure